Manchester united's colour is red.
They are the Red Devils,
they play in a stadium lined with red seats
and their red shirts are as famous
as the many iconic players to have worn them.
And yet over the past 12 years,
green and gold have in a way
become the club's colors too.
Why is that?
The green and gold campaign was
and remains
a visible protest against the Glazer family's ownership
of Manchester United.
But while the Glazer takeover was completed in 2005,
it wasn't until the beginning of 2010
that the green and gold coloured scarves
started to become truly visible at Old Trafford.
But why green and gold?
Well, Manchester United
only became Manchester United in 19 O 2.
Upon being founded,
the club was known as Newton Heath,
a railway workers team who played matches at the ground
to the northeast of Manchester city centre.
Accounts of Newton Heath's colours are varied,
but for a period of their short history
they certainly wore green and yellow
and that became the symbol of anti Glaser sentiment.
The idea for the campaign came from the hugely
influential
but now defunct
fanzine Red Issue.
The catalyst, however,
was bubbling resentment at the levels of debt
that had been hoisted on the club
as a result of the glazer's leveraged buyout
and the effect that had started to have on investment
in the club's first team.
In particular,
upon the publication of the club's accounts
for the two thousand And eight
nine period released.
In early 2010,
an alarming truth was revealed
according to a report in the Guardian.
The figures revealed that
without the sale of Cristiano Ronaldo
to Real Madrid for 80 one million pounds,
the colossal interest payments on the club's debt
would have meant a net loss
after a hugely successful season
in which the club won the Premier League
and reached the UEFA Champions League final.
In a book entitled Red Rebels
the glazes and the FC Revolution,
John Paul O'Neill recalled the birth of the campaign
and the speed with which momentum gathered around it.
The rapidity of its take up was spectacular.
He swag man
outside Old Trafford
struggled to cope with demand
for suddenly popular green and yellow scarves,
while the club's security
clamped down on any staff brandishing the colours.
That can be explained by strength of feeling, of course,
but also partially by context.
Debt was a very pertinent issue
in English football at the time
after their long term financial mismanagement.
Leeds united's demise
had concluded with relegation in 2004
and was still fresh in the mind.
Similarly, at the very
moment that Manchester united's Green and gold campaign
was gathering pace,
Portsmouth's financial debacle
was reaching its crescendo.
In February 2010,
with debts in excess of 70 million pounds,
they became the first Premier League club
to enter administration.
So fear surrounding financial instability
was at something of a zenith
and green and gold scarves
were suddenly Everywhere.
They were visible in significant
numbers at All Trafford
for the Premier League fixture against Hull City
and can very much be seen
on the highlights of the game today
as they can for the following home match in the league,
again coincidentally
against Portsmouth.
According to reporting by The Independent,
an estimated 30,000
scarves had been sold ahead of that game
and 1/5 of all fans inside the ground that day
were wearing one.
Ahead of the League Cup final in February,
when Manchester United beat Aston Villa
₩2 the United end was a wash with yellow and green
and ahead of kickoff
as players were walking out hundreds
more likely thousands of green and gold balloons
could be seen floating out from the stands
and there would be another vivid symbol
in the Champions League
at the end of the round of 16 victory over AC Milan
former United star David
Beckham had returned to Old Trafford as a Milan player
although well beaten on the night
and over the 2 legs
Beckham would linger on the pitch at full time
draping a supporter's green and yellow
scarf around his shoulders
after it had found its way onto the pitch
that memory's significance may have dwindled
as Beckham's career faded
and eventually finished
but the colours of united's protest
endure similarly
while the specific issue's animating support unrest
may have changed and diversified since 2010
the messaging in opposition to the ownership
has remained consistent
and still Highly visible within
those green and gold scarves.
If you like this video,
please like and follow tifo.
The athletic is home to some of the world's best
sports journalists,
including David Ornstein,
Daniel Taylor, Ollie K,
Amy Lawrence
and rapper Honagestein.
There are journalists dedicated to each Premier
League team
so every fan gets the coverage they deserve,
not just the big clubs.
And you can try it for free now
for 30 days.
See the link in our bio.